ce café a complètement changé la vie de
803 allen il a troqué son uniforme de
prisonnier pour son habit de barista il
y a deux mois à peine comment donner
cette chance et c'était un nouveau
départ pour moi je ne pouvais pas
refuser
c'est le tout premier emploi du jeune
écossais de 24 ans qui porte encore les
cicatrices de violentes batailles dans
lesquels il a été impliqué j'étais un
sans abri il ya quelques années je
devais vivre dans les rues et mendiait
pour obtenir de l'argent
c'était difficile et j'avais une
dépendance aux drogues étonnamment c'est
la police de glasgow qui lui a donné
cette deuxième chance par le biais d'une
escouade spéciale l'unité de la
réduction de la violence
créé il ya 15 ans glasgow avait alors
été déclarée capitale européenne du
meurtre par l'organisation mondiale de
la santé
incapable d'endiguer la violence les
forces policières ont dû revoir leur
approche réinventer leurs façons de
faire afin de mieux gérer la violence
pas question toutefois d'armé des
policiers qui n'utilise que des
matraques ni de les identifier avec des
uniformes aux allures militaires ou
encore des vestes pare-balles comme
c'est le cas au canada
nous avons décidé de regarder la
violence comme si c'était une maladie il
faut voir ça comme un enjeu de santé
publique comme si nous traitions une
épidémie de rougeole ou de tuberculose
l'unité de la réduction de la violence
adoptée une vaste approche tentaculaire
qui s'y attaquent sur plusieurs fronts
par le biais de nombreux programmes
sociaux comme le café street à nouveau
soutenu financièrement par l'unité est
dirigé par des policiers qui se
présentent ici en civil afin de tisser
des liens avec ces criminels qui n'ont
plus de repères lorsque prévenu sort de
prison
il réalise qu'il n'est rien autour de
lui il va alors commettre un autre crime
est retourné en prison
on travaille avec ses anciens criminels
pour les aider à rebâtir une résilience
ils sont jumelés à des mentors
edit goldman est l'un de ses mentors
après avoir passé 18 ans derrière les
barreaux pour trafic de drogue
il travaille désormais dans les urgences
de glasgow la nuit ses collègues et lui
ont pour mandat de repérer les membres
des gangs et des criminels admis à
l'hôpital après avoir été poignardé à
grenache et lorsque je rencontre un
patient dans sa civière qui vient tout
juste de se faire poignarder
je lui dis je ne sais pas comment tout
ça mais je sais comment je me sentais
quand je n'avais plus le contrôle de ma
vie et la proche de glasgow semble avoir
fait ses preuves depuis 2005 le taux de
criminalité a chuté de moitié moins de
meurtres et surtout moins d' attaque à
l'armé blanche à la création de cette
unité glasgow avait été le théâtre de 40
homicides
une dizaine d'années plus tard le nombre
de meurtres a chuté à 12
une diminution qui fait la vie de
nombreuses villes un peu partout dans le
monde on a eu un épais de l'australie la
semaine dernière du danemark
la semaine d'avant il y a un énorme
intérêt ottawa et toronto ont également
les yeux tournés vers glasgow
ces deux villes compose avec une
augmentation soutenue de la criminalité
mais jusqu'ici les forces policières
mise plutôt sur l'ajout de centaines de
policiers et de caméras de surveillance
dans les quartiers chauds n'est pas la
solution pour résoudre le problème vous
avez besoin davantage de travailleurs
sociaux
ce n'est qu'une question de priorité et
parmi ses priorités glasgow mis sur la
prévention du problème à la source les
jeunes
cette chirurgie maxillo faciale en a eu
assez de recevoir constamment les mêmes
patients dans son bureau de reconstituer
les mêmes visages défigurés
elle en parle aujourd'hui dans les
écoles
avec les adolescents on parle de ce
convoi l'hôpital de l'impact de la
violence dans une vie
l'ecosse regorge d'histoires à succès
depuis la création de cette unité de
réduction de la violence des scènes qui
font croire aux écossais qu'il est
possible d'exporter ses programmes
ailleurs comme au canada
whist son côté espère maintenant que ce
nouveau chapitre de sa vie sera aussi le
succès ici la peine son programme d'un
an dans ce café ils rêvent de trouver un
toit et fonder une famille
[Musique]